joining us now from the world Ag Expo in
California the chairman of the House
Intelligence community committees rather
Devin Nunez is with us Rob Rosenstein
this is the guy that recommended the
firing or call me this is a guy that
appointed Muller signed the final FISA
warrant application the third renewal
and this is a guy that Lisa Paige Andrew
McCabe and James Baker congressman all
say talked about wearing a wire against
President Trump in the hopes of invoking
the 25th amendment he owes us answers to
that he owes us answers he's not coming
tomorrow which I think should be very
telling the story is that he possibly
wanted to come and have a cup of coffee
with chairman Goodlatte well that's not
acceptable he needs to come and testify
under oath if you look at the story
tonight Sean that's breaking in The
Washington Post you have both McCabe and
Rosenstein fighting over what happened
at the time of when he wanted to wear a
wire whether or not he wanted to wear a
wire and and who is responsible for what
so clearly what this is is this is the
investigators who have no fun watching
them no one to investigate them and
they're running amuck running too much
so much they want you to come up that's
to fight a congress that's pretty
pathetic
they're both arguing over who should
have recused himself frankly both of
them should have recused themselves now
that we know what what we know with the
president said he'd be classify and send
out the unredacted FISA applications the
bulk of which the information came from
the phony dossier that Hillary paid for
and the FISA and the fraud on the FISA
Court where are those declassified
documents that the president said he'd
released where are the 302s between
Christopher's little Bruce or well the
same thing is true Shawn the same people
who are arguing tonight on the pages of
the Washington Post whether or not which
one should recuse themselves right so
this was over a year ago when the
special counsel was appointed they're
supposedly arguing in front of mole
who should be recused and like you said
they both should have been recused those
same people or at least the Deputy
Attorney General who will not come to
Congress to testify under oath is the
same person who is blocking the American
people from being able to see this
information that we and the Congress
have been asking for now a couple months
for the president Declassified the
president actually said I want this
immediately Declassified without Reid
actions and then shortly after that the
Deputy Attorney General convenes a
meeting to convince the president well
we need to have the IG look at this and
that's where we stand right now with the
classicizing you escalation if it can't
take 18 once Congress I don't think we
need an IG report shot I think it's
ridiculous Sean I agree neither do my
agree with you okay I don't have the
problem with IG I want this stuff
Declassified I agree wholeheartedly and
frankly a second special a real special
counsel ought to be appointed the FBI
director saying today he won't say
whether or not the president is being
wiretapped today are you kidding me I
mean yeah I don't know some of that
questioning goes a little different
directions but let's just go back to the
main point here that we need that we
really need to know at the start of the
special prosecutor special counsel when
remember people are losing sight of this
the chief investigators at the time had
no evidence of Trump campaign colluding
with Russians and so why did we have a
special counsel in the first place it
looks like she police it paid said they
had nothing in nine months so they
started a media leak strategy so they
can create the atmosphere of something
that never took place it is outrageous
chairman you've been amazing thank you
for being with us